If you’ve never had the pleasure of dining
in a Chuck E. Cheese’s restaurant before,
imagine for a moment an unending assault on
every single one of your senses at once while
a giant robotic rat mocks your existence with
a dead, lifeless stare and you’ve basically
got it.
Conceived by Atari co-founder Nolan Bushnell,
much like Atari itself (see our article here)
Chuck E. Cheese’s more or less bumbled its
way to success, inadvertently helping to change
the landscape of American family dining in
the process.
The story of Chuck E. Cheese’s can be traced
back to an epiphany Bushnell had while with
Atari.
Specifically, when he noticed that while Atari
could generally expect to make between $1,500
and $2,000 for every coin-operated arcade
machine they sold, the person buying them
could reliably expect the machine the generate
10 times that amount during its lifetime.
In Bushnell’s own words: “It didn’t
take rocket science to say I’m on the wrong
side of the equation.”
After a little research, Bushnell concluded
that maximising profits from arcade games
and the like was all about securing a location
and having a captive audience- two things
he reasoned he could easily achieve with a
restaurant.
Bushnell’s idea then was to create a restaurant
where food was, as he described, “an ancillary
service” and the real draw was the games
and entertainment.
Essentially, he wanted to create something
similar to a casino in Las Vegas (food, games,
and other entertainment), but for the whole
family.
To this end, Bushnell decided that his restaurant
should sell pizza, reasoning that it would
be impossible to screw up such a simple foodstuff
as long the ingredient were good.
This was important as he noted he really had
no idea how to run a restaurant business,
so keeping it simple was paramount.
A secondary reason Bushnell decided to sell
pizza instead of, say, fast-food style burgers
and fries, is that pizza has a built in “wait
time” once ordered- time that could be spent
playing the multitude of arcade games he planned
to outfit his restaurant with.
Knowing that parents would naturally want
to avoid a restaurant where the contents of
their wallet would be siphoned away by Pac
Man and his digital friends, Bushnell also
decided it would be a good idea to have other
forms of entertainment at his restaurants.
In his own words,
The reason for doing the animals, believe
it or not, was not for the kids.
It was meant to be a head fake for the parents.
Kids are really smart at knowing how to play
their parents.
and the kids knew that if they said, ‘I
want to go to Chuck E. Cheese and play the
games’ the parents would just see themselves
spending money.
But if they said, ‘I want to go see Chuck
E. Cheese entertainment — and it’s free,’
they’d be good to go.
The other thing was that we wanted the parents
to have something to amuse themselves while
the kids were in the game room.
If you listened to the dialogue, it was fun,
edgy stuff, kinda like Toy Story, written
as much for the parents as the kids.
Bushnell eventually settled on having this
entertainment meted out by animatronic animals
after a trip to the Tiki Room in Disneyland
and reasoning that making a robo-animal rap
or tell a joke would be child’s play for
his engineers.
According to Bushnell, the working name for
his pet project was originally Coyote Pizza.
As such, he bought a coyote costume he saw
at a tradeshow which he sent to his engineers
with a note instructing them to shove a robot
inside it and make it talk.
Unfortunately for Bushnell, what he had thought
was a coyote costume turned out to actually
be a rat, which his engineers dutifully pointed
out when he asked them, “How’s the coyote
coming?”
At that stage of the game, Bushnell decided
it would be easier to rename the restaurant
than, you know, sending the costume back and
getting a different one, so told his marketing
team he now wanted to call the restaurant
Rick Rat’s Pizza…
The marketing team, according to Bushnell,
“had a shitfit.
‘You can’t call a restaurant a rat place!
People think rats are dirty.
It’s not going to work.'”
Bushnell’s response was to tell them to
just pick another name then if it was such
a big deal, adding, “I don’t give a shit
what it is.
But it has to be happy.”
The name they eventually settled on was Chuck
E. Cheese’s, apparently because you have
to smile a couple times while saying it…
Amazingly the scheme worked, and the chain
exploded in popularity.
Even after a pretty catastrophic fall in much
more modern times when the games and entertainment
there became more than antiquated, the company
still managed to sell for just shy of $1 billion
in 2014, with the new ownership taking steps
to modernize the whole affair, and well over
600 locations still in operation world-wide
today.